Speaker 1: Speaking of good signs, a very
bad situation for an Alaska state senator
is that Alaska Airlines has banned her from
flying on Alaska Airlines.
I'm talking here about State Senator Laura
Reinbold.
Tim Thompson, spokesman for Alaska Airlines,
told the Anchorage Daily News over the weekend,
quote, We have notified Senator Laura Reinbold
that she is not permitted to fly with us for
her continued refusal to comply with employee
instruction regarding the current mask policy.
Apparently, she has not only been refusing
to wear a mask, she was even recorded arguing
at Juneau International Airport, arguing with
an Alaska Airlines staff member about mask
policy.
And the video appears to show airline staff
telling her the mask must be on.
It must cover your mouth.
It must also cover your nose like the basics,
we're going back to March 20 20 unmasking
and she had been apparently asking about a
mask exemption with upright employees, with
uptight employees at the counter.
She said I was reasonable with all Alaska
Airlines employees and that she did ultimately
board the flight.
But she's been vocally opposed to any covid-19
mitigation measures.
She has objected to the Alaska Airlines mask
policy that was enacted before the federal
government enacted a mask policy.
Alaska Airlines had already been saying even
before Biden came in.
You have to wear a mask.
She's been calling Alaska Airlines staff mask
bullies.
And when she was asked by flight attendants
when boarding the flight to put the mask on,
I guess she went nuts and then has sent some
kind of apology to the staff.
It's all completely crazy.
And this is the only airline she can take
to go from between Anchorage and Juneau unless
she starts flying private or like, could she
connect somewhere in the mainland?
Imagine having to fly from Juneau to like
Seattle and then Seattle to Anchorage because
she's banned.
Actually, even that flight, I think, is only
in Alaska.
And I don't know what the hell she's going
to do, quite frankly, because if you're an
Alaska state senator needing to regularly
get back and forth to Anchorage, there aren't
really other options other than Alaska Airlines.
And, you know, I know a lot of people in the
audience have dealt with the mass stuff when
flying, but you don't necessarily expect it
from a sitting state senator.
Even on my flight, I talked about this on
my I flew a different not Alaska Airlines,
which as far as I know, Alaska Airlines is
being really good on the mask stuff.
Not every airline is.
I flew a different airline to Aruba last month,
fully vaccinated, of course, and with a mask
and everything.
And there was absolutely no enforcement of
masking.
There were a lot of people sitting near me
who were playing sort of coy with the food
and drink policy, where even though the airline
announced multiple times, if you were actively
eating or drinking, you can take your mask
off.
If you are between sips or bites, put the
mask on.
And there were a bunch of people on the plane
who were doing the thing where they take the
mask off and they hold their drink up.
So they appear to be in the process of actively
drinking and then they just watch a two hour
movie on the TV screen and just hold the drink.
There was no enforcement whatsoever.
At one point I saw a woman get up from her
seat and go to the bathroom, walk by flight
attendants with just no mask, and then walk
back to her seat.
And I'd say half of the people near me, the
mask wasn't even covering the nose.
And, you know, as I said, I wouldn't have
traveled if I weren't vaccinated.
So I wasn't bothered in that I was, you know,
hiding, thinking I'm going to get sick.
You needed a negative to everybody on the
plane, needed a negative test in order to
board.
And I was vaccinated.
It wasn't because of that.
But if the rules are right now to fly, you
wear the mask.
I'm going to play the game.
If I don't want to wear the mask on the plane,
I'll just say I'm not going to travel for
the time being because I wanted to travel.
I wore the mask.
Whatever I think about my personal level of
risk, that I think is what's frustrating,
which is, you know, the rules when you get
on, you're told when you book the flight,
you're told when you check in for the flight,
you're not even allowed near the gate without
a mask, you're told, via announcements.
And then for Laura Reinbold to just continue
arguing about this, you don't have to fly.
Now, you might say, well, she does have to
fly.
She has to get back and forth from Anchorage
to Juneau because she's a state senator.
Well, OK.
She could look at driving.
She could look at chartering a plane.
She doesn't have to fly on Alaska Airlines,
nor does she have a right to fly on Alaska
Airlines.
And she is now banned from Alaska Airlines.
No word on how she will commute for her work
as an Alaska state senator.
It's not going to be that much longer, guys.
If you're supposed to wear the mask, just
wear the mask.